what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder i'm your host
warren thompson and today we have some
very very exciting fantastic four news
we're going to be talking about a brand
new report today and we're also going to
be talking about the upcoming d23 expo
held by disney where we should be
getting a lot of marvel content
including possibly an announcement for
the fantastic four cast now at this
year's san diego comic con kevin feige
revealed that the fantastic four is
going to be kicking off the mcu's phase
six on november 8
2024 so we basically have pretty much
two years to go however marvel studios
has actually been working on the
fantastic four for quite some time now
marvel studios over a year ago announced
that director john watts the director of
the spider-man homecoming trilogy and
recently spider-man no way home which is
one of the biggest box office movies of
all time was supposed to direct
fantastic four they announced that he
would be directing the movie however
after spider-man no way home came out
john watts back down because he needed a
break from superhero movies and he made
one of the biggest movies of all time
spider-man no way home and leading up to
that had to be stressful with people
like me leaking just about every detail
of the movie but one can understand how
he would need a break from directing
superhero films after directing a crazy
awesome franchise but now we have news
that a new director has been chosen from
marvel studios and it actually lines up
with some other rumors that we've heard
recently now a lot of people have been
reporting on this today however a few
days ago the direct actually reported on
this rumor first i believe they were
first at least on august 24th they said
according to the direct sources one
division director matt shakman is signed
on to direct marvel studios as fantastic
four hitting theaters on november 8th
2024 shackman will replace spider-man
director john watts at the helm
following his departure from the project
in april 2022 now i actually think that
matt shakman is a really good choice i
think he would do great at directing the
fantastic four i think one division was
amazing it's one of my favorite disney
plush shows that alongside of loki of
course and a lot of people really liked
wanda vision now of course the fantastic
four is going to be a very different
movie and of course they're going to
have writers assigned to write the movie
as well so it's not just going to be
matt shakman but as far as the direction
goes i think he's a pretty good choice
now today other outlets are reporting on
this news as well deadline reported this
morning after playing a big part in
helping launch the marvel studios
limited series one division matt shakman
may be ready to help launch one of the
studios as prized movie properties
sources tell deadline that shakman is in
early talks to direct marvel's new
fantastic four pick rumors have been
running rampant in recent weeks that he
was in the mix for the job and insiders
are now telling deadline that while a
formal offer hasn't been presented early
discussions have begun and that things
are headed in the right direction marvel
studios president kevin feige is
producing marvel could not be reached
for comment so this further backs up the
directs report that matt shackman is
indeed going to be the director of the
fantastic four movie now here's
something that is really really
interesting and we are going to be
talking about the cast of the fantastic
four and d23 in just a bit but earlier
on in the year when john watts stepped
down from directing the fantastic four
deadline actually reported that they
would be shocked if a choice is made
before labor day referring to a new
director for the fantastic four however
labor day is september 5th so we are
before labor day so it seems like marvel
studios has made their choice before
labor day and this is a good sign two
reasons it's a good sign one is that if
they are making this decision before
labor day they must feel really really
good about matt shakman directing the
new fantastic four in the mcu obviously
they have met with him he shared his
vision for the movie marvel shared their
vision for the movie and they both are
kind of on the same page and like the
direction that matt shachman would take
the film they clearly liked it a lot if
they've pretty much made their decision
before labor day and that's awesome that
means marvel has faith in him so
hopefully the movie is going to be
fantastic under his direction but here's
something else that is really really
exciting it seems like marvel studios
wanted to make a decision before d23 now
i briefly stated this before but if
you're not familiar with what the d23
expo is it's a three-day event held by
disney where they're different companies
inside of them like marvel studios
lucasfilm pixar etc get their own panels
and get their own time to talk about
current and future projects it's pretty
much like a panel at san diego comic con
although i believe marvel studios gets a
little bit more time at d23 but
essentially we get the same reveals and
we're hoping and we're assuming that
we're going to get the entirety of phase
six revealed at sdcc they revealed all
of phase five but only a little bit of
phase six but we assumed that they were
only going to reveal a part of it
because they have to release more things
at d23 to make d23 exciting and of
course we're looking forward to the new
titles that haven't been announced yet
however there is a possibility that they
could give us more information about the
fantastic four because it does seem like
marvel studios wanted to lock down the
director before d23 happened so they
could possibly make an announcement this
is a great sign but here's the other
thing the fantastic four is kevin
feige's baby he has stated many many
times how important marvel's first
family is to him so he's been working on
this for a while and he's going to be
making sure this movie is done right and
there's only about two years left until
the movie which means they could have
already actually cast some actors as
part of the fantastic four they could
actually already have the villain for
the fantastic four film as well and
since marvel had john watts directing
the film over a year ago and now has
matt shakman about to jump on the
project i'm assuming they have a general
outline of what the story is actually
going to be in the film so i'm sure they
know who the villain is going to be and
i'm sure they know or at least have a
general idea of the actors they want to
play these roles and i'm sure that
they've already talked to them about it
and one thing that's pretty cool and
also very interesting is that it seems
like if kevin feige comes across
somebody who is perfect for a particular
role he will give them that role right
then and there for example i once
interviewed tren tran an executive
producer at marvel studios and i talked
about the first time that she met with
haley steinfeld about the role of kate
bishop her and kevin feige met with her
one single time and in that meeting
kevin feige offered her the role of kate
bishop because she was perfect they
didn't meet with anybody else so if
kevin feige meets with somebody and
determines that they are perfect for a
role he will give them that role and
since kevin feige has been focused on
the fantastic four for a very long time
now i'm talking years i'd actually be
shocked if he hasn't picked the cast for
the fantastic four yet now i'm not
really assuming they're going to present
us with the cast of the fantastic four
at d23 however we know that they needed
to save some pretty big announcements
for d23 and at sdcc they announced some
major projects like the release date for
the fantastic four and of course
avengers the king dynasty and avengers
secret wars those are huge announcements
so it makes you wonder what
announcements could be coming at d23 and
in my mind i think that if marvel
studios wants to announce something big
it would be the cast of the fantastic
four now of course we're going to get an
announcement for things like deadpool 3
and hopefully a mutant's project fingers
crossed on that one but i wouldn't be
surprised if we get the director
announcement and maybe even some type of
a casting announcement but that is no
way confirmed that is just my opinion
just connecting the dots here but either
way we know marvel studios has some
pretty big announcements in line for us
at d23 so let me know what you would
like to see from d23 in the comments
down below please don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest mcu news
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof